the forearm Commonwealth and development
office leads our work on sanctions and
we've already designated more than 350
individuals and organizations linked to
the Iranian regime covering their
military security and Judiciary and we
have sanctioned the Islamic
revolutionary guard Corps in its
entirety
and our diplomatic network is
coordinating with our friends and allies
around the world to reinforce our
response including the United States of
America
Australia New Zealand Canada and the
European Union
the Cowardly attacks planned by the
Iranian regime on British soil violate
the most Elementary rules of diplomatic
relations between states I have twice
summoned Iran's most senior diplomats in
London to explain his government
activities most recently following Iran
International's decision to temporarily
relocate their broadcasting Services it
is intolerable that any media outlet
should be forced to leave the United
Kingdom because of the Iranian regime
and its threats to kidnap or murder
their journalists Miss Deputy speaker I
have no doubt that every part of this
house will share my outrage
and there is clear evidence that the
Iranian regime continues to prepare
operations against individuals in Europe
and Beyond we have made representations
to the Iranian foreign Ministry we
emphasize in no uncertain terms our
determination to pursue any Iranian
agent who would harm the UK or our
allies we will also continue to work
with our International Partners to
identify to expose and to counter
threats made against us
but the UK is clear that we need to go
further
so today I am announcing to the house
further measures
they constitute a toolkit that I would
prefer
not to use
but the decision on whether I do so or
whether I do not is firmly in the hands
of the Iranian regime itself
turning to the measures
first we will establish a new Iran
sanctions regime
this will be the whole the first holy
Geographic autonomous sanctions regime
that the UK has created since leaving
the European Union it will give us new
and enhanced powers to counter Iran's
hostile and destabilizing activities in
the UK and around the world allowing us
to impose asset freezes and travel bans
on more of Iran's decision makers and
those doing its bidding in particular we
will have broader powers to Target those
involved in the regime's efforts to
undermine peace stability and Security
in the region and internationally
to address those who proliferate arms or
weapons technology from Iran those who
undermine democracy undermine the
respect for the rule of law and
undermine good government governance and
those who carry out other hostile
activities towards the UK and our
partners including threats to our people
property or national security
and we expect to bring the necessary
legislation to Parliament later on this
year
secondly I can tell the house that today
we have designated a further 13
individuals and entities responsible for
serious human rights violations inside
Iran this package of sanctions includes
five senior officials from Iran's
notorious prison system which is Rife
with torture and abuse of prisoners it
includes further measures to targeting
the Supreme Council of the cultural
revolution as the organization that
enforces social and cultural norms that
oppress Iranian citizens themselves
and we target six key actors responsible
for suppressing freedom of expression
online
including the Islamic revolutionary
guard course cyber Defense command and
the Supreme Council for cyberspace Miss
Deputy speaker our actions are a direct
response to the escalation of Iran's
reprehensible behavior in the UK we are
not seeking to escalate our aim is to
prevent and deter hostile Iranian
activity on British soil as well as on
the territory of our partners and allies
let us remind ourselves Iran is selling
drones to Russia they are attacking
their neighbors they even attack their
own people when they stand up for human
rights and the most basic of freedoms it
is my fervent hope
that there will be brighter days ahead
for the relationship between our two
countries but we cannot take any steps
in that direction until the regime
ceases its deplorable activities and
until that day comes we will remain
steadfast in our efforts to stop Iranian
aggression and to protect the United
Kingdom I commend this statement to the
house
David Lame
yeah
for Mr Deputy speaker I'm grateful to my
right honorable friend for advanced
sight and notice of his statement
in the last year the charge sheet
against the government of Iran has grown
and grown
it has funded violent militia across the
Middle East
it has supplied drones to Russia that
Menace Ukraine cities kill civilians and
Destroy infrastructure
it has continued to pursue its nuclear
program and breach of international
commitments and it is brutally
suppressed the protests of young
Iranians who dared to demand a better
future
and in the last 12 months it has
executed more people than almost any
country in the world
it continues to detain UK Iranian dual
Nationals included including Murad tabaz
and Moran
Ralph
and continues to harass and threaten
dissidents even those who've made their
home here in the United Kingdom
that the security services have foiled
15 plots against british-based
individuals shows the scale of this
hostile activity
this worsening extraterritorial threat
must be met with strong and clear action
we cannot tolerate efforts to harass
silence or threaten the welfare or
regime critics here in the United
Kingdom and we must ensure that Iranian
and British journalists can operate
without fear or intimidation
the end of last year I called for the
United Nations Human Rights Council to
urgently investigate Iran's Crackdown on
protesters and for the government to
bring forward stronger sanctions against
the Iranian regime
labor has also called for a new joint
fcdo home office State threat cell to
coordinate the action in government so
we welcome the measures that the foreign
secretary has announced today
the government will be aware of the
long-standing strength of feeling from
many sides of the house and from members
of the Iranian diaspora on the question
of prescription of the irgc labor
proposed a new mechanism for
prescription for state-linked actors in
The National Security bill but the
government unfortunately did not support
it I understand of course that there are
diplomatic Dimensions to this question
but I'm sure this house would welcome an
update from him on the issue I also want
to ask the foreign secretary about the
fate of UK Iranian dual Nationals labor
has for a long time called for a new
legal right for Consular assistance to
help protect British Nationals
the government has rejected this
in April the Foreign Affairs select
committee put forward proposals to
overhaul the way the foreign office
tries to secure the release of British
Nationals overseas today the government
has largely rejected these two
is the foreign office complacent on this
issue and what steps will it take to
bring British Nationals detained in Iran
and elsewhere home
finally I wanted to ask about the future
of the jcpoa
we supported the nuclear agreement as
the best approach to preventing Iran
acquiring a nuclear weapon and we remain
determined and committed to the vital
non-proliferation goal however there is
a clear and ongoing pattern of Iran
breaching the jcpoa's terms preventing
monitoring and verification and
enriching uranium past the point of any
civilian justification and it's
continued to violate U.N security
Council resolution 2231 including in its
ballistic missile activities
the UK has a responsibility as one of
the signatories of the jcpoa to take a
leading role in containing Iran's
nuclear Ambitions and its related
activities so can I ask the foreign
secretary about the prospects of
negotiations on what some are calling a
less for Less deal
Mr Deputy speaker Iran is a country with
an extraordinary and ancient history
it's courageous people who've risked
their lives over the past year in
pursuit of Freedom they deserve a
government that respects their rights
until that day labor will continue to
support action to hold the Iranian
regime to account
yeah
Mr Stephanie speak I
got the right honorable gentleman's
comments about the Iranian people
and I've said it before but I said again
our quarrel is not with the Iranian
people
Iran is a country as he says with a huge
and fabulous history a sophisticated
people but sadly they are being let down
badly by those who are in positions of
leadership
he asked in our position he answers to
update our position on prescription
oppositional on prescription I've
discussed in the dispatch box before we
will always keep under review the
response uh to Iranian State threats and
other threats some of which I've laid
out in my uh statement to the house
today the rgc is sanctioned in its
entirety in certain individuals within
it are individually sanctioned as well
but as I say we do not regularly comment
on future prescriptions or designations
um but we do always keep our options
under review he makes point with regard
to uh the nature of our Consular support
the government's position we do not need
a law
for the government to derive by British
people overseas we extend Consular
assistance to British Nationals without
need for legislation instructing us to
do so and we do so even when the
attention of a house is not focused on
those individuals there are many cases
where we've had very successful Consular
outcomes for individuals who have never
come into the consciousness of this
house we seek to do so always with the
best interests of those British
Nationals at our heart he will know that
with regard to Iran
in certain circumstances it is
particularly difficult for us to
discharge our duty and our
responsibility for continuing Services
particularly of those people who are
British dual Nationals because Iran does
not recognize your national uh status
but nevertheless we will always seek to
do right by those people who are
incarcerated around the world and indeed
those people who are still in custody
incarcerated in Iran
and he speaks to the jcpoa he is
absolutely right
um that the UK is focused on ensuring
that Iran does not acquire nuclear
weapons Technologies or capabilities we
work in close coordination with our
friends in the E3 in the United States
of America on this it is a regular
subject of conversation that I have with
foreign minister colleagues across the
quad and I can reassure him and the
house they're preventing the acquisition
of nuclear weapons technology will
remain a priority the priority uh within
our Iran strategy and we will continue
to explore ways of deterring Iran's
pursuit of a nuclear weapon and
preventing it from happening
when I first select committee Alicia
Keys thank you Mr Deputy speaker can I
welcome this new geographically
autonomous sanctions regime it is an
important step in demonstrating that
defense is not an escalation and we will
be strong at home I also welcome the
referral yesterday of Iran to the icg as
a result of the shooting down of the
Ukrainian aircraft in 2020 which is the
UK in 2020 which the UK is doing with
our allies that again is a good step as
The Honorable gentleman said this
morning we did release our report into
hostage taking and can I urge my rotten
friend to give us an update on more rad
to burst because it matters that his
name is heard time and time again
particularly given how ILY is and
finally given that we have now created
an autonomous regime can I urge my
honorable friend to consider regime on
the Chinese Communist party they have
sanctions as house they continually
perpetrate transnational oppression and
this week alone they put bounties on the
heads of three individuals who sought
Refuge here and can I also ask them to
haul in the Chinese ambassador to raise
help unacceptable this is and have seen
and in breach of international law it is
speaker my honorable friend raises
important points and I welcome uh her
comments on the structures that we have
put in place today and we're putting
forward with legislation to the house in
due uh course
uh we recognize that no one element of
our response on its own will resolve all
these issues but they do have a
cumulative effects and I can assure her
that we continue to work in close
coordination with our International
allies to maximize the impact of our
sanctions response and to ensure that
Iran recognizes as she said in her
question that this is a response to
their actions if they do not like this
response they should change their
actions and with regard to uh sanctions
for other nations she will know but the
house and the department have heard the
point that she's made she will know that
we do not routinely speculate on
sanctions that we may bring forward but
I can assure her that whenever
I have interactions with representatives
of the Chinese government I raise uh
Hong Kong and the sanctioning of British
parliamentarians and the uh fundamental
disagreement we have with their actions
in uh in relation to the weaker Muslims
at every single opportunity
yeah into nohara
just a deputy speaking I think the fund
secretary for prior site of his
statement I'd like to begin by putting
on record the snp's broad support for
this wide-ranging package of measures to
be taken against the regime in Tehran
and the full secretary was absolutely
right when he says that the exporting of
international terrorism by Iran cannot
and will not and must not be tolerated
in much of what is in this statement is
what we and these benches indeed this
entire house have been calling on for
some time but can I helpfully suggest
that the legislation which will come
before the end of the year needs to come
as quickly as possible and if the phone
sector could even roughly put a date on
when that might happen that would be
helpful I'm pleased that action has been
taken against those who are complicit in
doing this brutal regimes and bidding
whether it be military security or the
Judiciary and I welcome the news that
five of the most senior officials from
that barbaric prison system have been
signed II particularly those in the
notorious Evan prison which nasdine
zagaria Radcliffe was held in which used
as a brutal tool of retression against
those many Brave young women who
recently stood up against the regime are
where they were held tortured and
murdered within that system
could I also ask the the foreign
secretary to explain why the Islamic
revolutionary guard Corps have been
sanctioned and not prescribed we were
told six months ago by the security
minister that they were to be prescribed
as a terrorist organization and I think
many of us on seeing the statement being
held in would have thought that that
would have been part of it and what the
difference between a sanctioned
organization and a prescribed
organization is and finally Mr Deputy
speaker in light of what was contained
are the continued support that Iran has
for Russia's illegal war in Ukraine
why is this department not tightened up
further those iran-specific export
controls and sanctions on those dual use
companies to stop the export of
materials to Iran from the UK that could
subsequently be made into weapons thank
you
Mr Speaker I
Thank The Honorable gentleman for
welcoming the measures that we have
taken he asked once again about
prescription
um and he will he will have heard my uh
earlier response we always keep options
available I I think within his question
he
I think outlines one of the uh one of
the key issues on this he says that he
is his party are calling on the UK
government to prescribe the irgc and
then he goes on to say that he would
like an explanation the difference
between prescription and sanctions and I
recognize that people see prescription
as the most desired outcome without
necessarily uh understanding that much
of what I suspect people want to see
from what they believe to be the outcome
of prescription is actually already in
place asset freezes uh travel bans
um and uh the say the suite of responses
is kept constantly under review but I
can assure always take actions as we've
set out in the statement today we will
always take actions that we believe are
in the best interest of protecting the
British Nationals both here and overseas
and also those Iranians who have made
their home in the um in the in the UK he
asked about the timetabling for
legislation
um the house will understand that is
something that I'll need to discuss over
the leader of the house and the business
managers but I can assure him that we
regard our response to Iran as a
priority and we'll seek to bring this
forward with as much expediency as we're
able
Teresa Villas
constituent of mine is on repeated
occasions raised serious concerns about
the connections between the Islamic
Center of England and the irgc in the
office of the supreme leader he also
believes there could be such connections
between the supreme leader and a Islamic
Center in Manchester so what is the
government doing to ensure that uk-based
Charities like these two are can in no
way ever be a threat to the security of
Iranian dissidents in the United Kingdom
uh my right woman friend raises a very
important Point
um uh my department have discussed this
with a home office and indeed I have
discussed this with my right honorable
friend the security minister I can
reassure her and the house that he takes
very seriously very seriously indeed the
actions of organizations uh that she has
mentioned
um and obviously we uh wish to ensure
that the charity commission also fully
discharges its duty to make sure that
any organization under its remit is not
used to harass or persecute foreign
Nationals or indeed British people here
in the UK
Anderson
thank you Mr Deputy speaker
issues that are by Iranian s especially
women are
really by constituents in Putney and
South fields and Roehampton I'm stopped
in the street many times to talk about
this issue
British Iranian dual National Murad
tabaz has already been mentioned in this
statement he remains arbitrarily
detained in terrible conditions in Iran
almost four years after he was sentenced
in 2019 could the foreign secretary say
more about the to the house about the
last time that he raised morad's case
with his Iranian counterparts and what
strategy is in place to secure his
release difficult though that is
uh Mr Speaker I uh the last time I had
face-to-face uh contact with a a
represent a representative minister of
the Iranian regime Wars uh
in 21.
um but my officials regularly raise uh
Consular issues including detainees with
our Iranian counterparts I can assure
her and the house that this remains a
priority I have met with Maura to baza's
family on a number of occasions my right
honorable friend the minister for the
region Lord Ahmed has met with them very
recently I think within the last few
weeks this remains a priority for us and
I can assure her that we will continue
to work with the United States America
because he's a tri-national to bring
about his permanent release and ability
to come home and rejoin his family
Dr Richard
speaker in welcoming these sanctions can
I ask the foreign secretary to look at
Iran's activities elsewhere he's already
mentioned the Russian uh drones
provision Russian drones I hear rumors
that Iran have also provided uh drones
for the polisaria in in southern Algeria
which could destabilize a very fragile
piece with the Moroccans in Western
Sahara a space that's governed by the UN
indeed it's perfectly credible that the
Iranians are also involved in places
like to Gray and South Sudan are
destabilizing a whole continent as a
lever of political power
am I my right honorable friend who knows
the continent of Africa and its politics
incredibly well is absolutely right to
highlight the fact that Iran Iranian
malign activity is not restricted to its
own near neighborhood or indeed the
United Kingdom we look very carefully at
the credible reporting of the support
through military equipment not just to
Russia in their attack against Ukraine
about militia groups and other military
groups in the region and across Africa
and I can I can reassure him that we
will absolutely take that into
consideration when it comes to any
future sanctions response that we have
towards the Iranian regime in America
Deputy speaker may I start by welcoming
the statement and I look forward to
supporting the legislation so it can
pass as quickly as possible we are all
anxious to do whatever we can to support
the people of Iran now Mata amini was an
inspiration to women not just in her own
country but across the world and the
fact that the people who did this to her
the irgc have not been held to account
is itself a tragedy would the foreign
secretary back the campaign therefore to
rename the street of the Iranian Embassy
after her so that every business card
every email every piece of post that
they have to receive and send has her
name on it it worked with South Africa
and Nelson Mandela I think the time is
not right to do it for her now
uh honorable heavy makes
an incredibly important point about the
courage of Iranian women the courage
genuinely beyond measure I have seen
open source footage of Iranian women and
actually Iranian men standing up against
the so-called morality police and uh and
others she will know that the the naming
of thorough Affairs is not a decision
for central government but rather for a
local government which makes an
incredibly important point and perhaps
the uh perhaps the planning committee of
the uh of the local Council might take
that on board
Bradley
Mr Speaker
urge group of the interparliamentary
Union hosted an event for BBC Persian
where we heard incredibly powerful
testimony from the journalists that were
reporting on the very incident that The
Honorable lady opposite uh referred to
those women's protests the the freedom
of those journalists report is under
great threat from the Iranian regime so
I welcome very much what the my
reasonable friends has announced today
but can he confirm both the government's
support for the continuation of BBC
Persian service and the Tehran
International will be able to return to
the UK
at my right honorable friend Echoes the
government strength feeling about media
freedom I can reassure her and the house
that in my conversations with the very
very senior leadership of the BBC I made
a specific point about the importance of
BBC Persia as part of the uh wider uh
positive influence on the world that BBC
World Service has had we came to a
funding arrangement with the BBC World
Service to ensure that certainly for the
life of this Parliament there will be no
language Services closed because I
recognize that in times of
disinformation and Times of Oppression
the voices of Truth and freedom as
personified by the hard-working uh
colleagues in the BBC Persian service is
more important than ever
very much except I'm slightly puzzled at
the performance actually just told the
little Democrat spokesperson that uh
foreign policy decisions can be passed
to local authorities I don't know what
the uh the leveling up Factory would say
about that but I'm concerned very much
by what he said a few moments ago about
uh in relation to my Constitution at
Barry who was executed as he knows
earlier this year that he said that he
hadn't had any contact Direct contact
with the Iranian regime for two years
now I know that the family wanted him to
do that there are there remain people
like moretabaz who are in custody in
Tehran does he not think he should be
doing more to try and get them released
from that way and that talking to the
regime may be necessary
I know the honorable gentleman had a
long career in local government before
he came to this house perhaps he would
understand that street naming is not a
foreign policy issue
it really is not
um I and I can I can assure him that uh
we do have regular and Senior uh contact
with representatives of the Iranian
government uh the Iranian regime has
made it through their own actions
they've made it harder for me to have
engagement uh with them however that is
not a blanket ban on engagement if I can
assure him that the plight of detainees
and our desire to have them released and
returned home is a very high priority in
all the conversations that we have at
all levels with representatives of the
Iranian government
thank you Mr Deputy speaker I welcome
the action that my writable friend has
announced to the house this afternoon I
think it's really important that the
house should remain United and
clear-sighted about the need to confront
Iran's Behavior the foreign secretary
mentioned Russia's use of Iranian drone
technology in Ukraine we also understand
that Putin is seeking to acquire Iran's
ballistics weapons technology as well
now it's my understanding that a sunset
clause in the jcpoa if activated by the
UK and the EU would allow that to happen
from October so could the foreign
secretary give a strong Assurance of the
house this afternoon that he will work
in lockstep with our colleagues in the
EU to make sure that Nev doesn't happen
my right honorable friend makes a very
important point with regard to our
policy towards Russia's invasion of
Ukraine working to ensure that Russia is
not supported through uh military
equipment exports is one of our priority
functions and that is particularly true
with regard to Iranian Technologies
whether it be drone Technologies or
others I absolutely take the point that
he makes about the sunset Clauses and
jcpoa we are very alive to that it's a
conversation I've regularly have with my
E3 and United States counterparts and I
can reassure him that preventing that
brutal technology falling into the hands
of Russia or indeed anyone else remains
an absolute priority for the government
but thank you Mr Deputy speaker Iran has
made no secret of its efforts to arm
fund and train Palestinian Terror groups
in the West Bank the leader of
Palestinian Islamic Jihad has even said
that its terrorists depend on Iranian
supplied Weaponry the very same group
which has turned genin into a city of
Terror so I'm sure my writable friend
will agree with me that we should
condemn this destabiling activity but
far more than that it is horrendous
examples such as this that double
underline the need for the very welcome
toolkit of measures he has announced
this afternoon not just to have them in
our own Arsenal but to use them
Miss Deputy speaker I commend my
honorable friend with the uh for the for
the for the for the for the passion and
consistency of his championing of uh
this uh of this issue uh I I completely
agree with him that that the the support
for violence and terrorism not just in
the West Bank but more broadly across
the Middle East uh is is is completely
wrong and we will always stand up
against it the sad truth the sad truth
is that the Palestinian people
suffer because of the export of Iranian
violence into the region we continue to
work as a Cornerstone of our foreign
policy to bring about peace between the
Israeli people and the Palestinian
people that is not helped by the violent
interference of Iran and we will
continue to take action to deter and
prevent it
thank you Mr Deputy speaker I very much
welcome this package of strengthened
sanctions last weekend I attended the
free Iran Global Summit which was
attended by a range of former Prime
Ministers former vice presidents uh
former foreign ministers representatives
from 52 parliaments and around 10
members and former members from across
this place which roundly of course
condemns the gross violations of human
rights in Iran particularly the 300 uses
of the death penalty the oppression of
women but the killing also of 70
innocent children through shooting and
poisoning the the conference uh
discussed the issue of the Iran
revolutionary guard corpse now I've
heard what my right honorable friend has
said about prescription of the the
organization in its entirety but would
he assure me that he would keep that
step very much under close review
I I can assure my I can assure my
honorable friend
uh that we take a a thoughtful approach
but a firm and decisive approach to our
posture with regard to uh Iran uh I will
always keep all options under a review
uh we will always act in what we believe
to be the best interests of our own
security but also the Safety and
Security of our friends in the region
and indeed as I as she has said the
Iranian people who find themselves
brutalized by their own government and
so when I say we keep these things under
review I genuinely mean it and nothing
in terms of our response would be put uh
permanently off the table or Beyond use
but the announcements that I made today
added to the pre-existing uh sanctions
packages gives us a powerful tool of
deterrent for Iranian Behavior which we
intend to utilize fully if Iran's
Behavior doesn't change I will finish on
this point Mr Deputy speaker
the power
is in Iran's hands were they to change
their behavior were they to stop funding
terrorism and militia groups in the area
were they to stop pursuing nuclear
weapons and were they to stop
brutalizing their people we would be
able to change our posture towards them
the power is in their hands